yeah hello welcome to our live show
Monday evening blitz yup really looking
forward to that I haven't played blitz
games for quite a while to be honest
didn't do much on my channel last week
I've been very busy with stuff yeah
welcome to all of you in the chat what's
the optimal amount of classical games
per year to play hmm yah it's difficult
to say I'm going to request the Blitz
game now and see what happens um how
many games one per week is an answer in
the chat yeah that's not such a bad idea
like 50 games sounds sounds quite okay
um I think 1550 is great if you can get
that in I have to admit that I rarely
managed to do that I probably am on
roughly thirty per year which is not
much but game started but it's not bad
either playing jolly scold she said okay
so what am I going to do maybe some
Kings Indiana for a change I've got the
f3 line the same ish yeah what did I
usually i played i played 96 a6 but
let's see what happens after is 6cm
usual is Cochise Bishop d3 yeah maybe I
can do like this with c5 you probably
play Knight G to e2 hero and maybe I can
switch to a b5
yeah I mean you can play much more games
than 50 I mean this is definitely what
many players did yeah Luke and really
for example he's well known for having
played much more um actually I missed
the tactic that's Knight takes e4 him I
didn't miss a tactic I just have played
e5 I came but now I came to play Knight
takes e4 mini-game says it's not the
quantity it's the quality of the games
and in some way that is true I mean if
you um play em events I'd rather play oh
wow he gives the Queen and that's a
drastic measure okay so yeah I can just
take the bishop I mean yes what does he
have the knight Knight and rook and for
the Queen and so I think what is really
true is if you play games it makes sense
to choose carefully
what kind of tournament you play I think
it is very much different for everybody
what kind of tournament you should play
for example um I have decided a while
ago that I'm not going to play
tournaments that have more than one
double round because I simply hate the
idea of playing so much chess on one day
as simply don't don't like Adam it
doesn't really fit well with my physical
fitness and stuff like that I don't like
it so I don't play those events and I
think you should also choose carefully
what kind of conditions what kind of
what kind of turn the mid hall for
example there is it the main thing is
you should feel comfortable and
well equipped to play to play decently
so rather one really good tournament
that you enjoy then like three crappy
ones here Jack okay
he checks me I'm going to go to the
corner yeah this BB pawn yeah
so I was thinking like c5 before yeah
we'd also have football on right yeah
you know um you have bio flashlights
this is a little burn ready masters I
wouldn't care about two games I know
you're totally right I wouldn't care
because um this is not a rated
tournament this is more for for fun
and this is okay but I don't I wouldn't
want to play rated games lots of rated
games on one day it doesn't doesn't make
much sense to me okay I can give the
check on before king bee 393 and there
is rupee AIDS but I'm not a chicken
mated down I'm not but you know I mean I
can just develop stuff here and prevent
any counter play I'm a queen up
I think the best system against the same
issues probably c5 tofo be Nonis this
diagonal looks dangerous for black okay
I can play Knight takes d4 here right
check check
white resigns yeah he overlooked that
Knight takes e4 tactic here that was
winning the house okay let's go for a
new game yeah what what game is on
actually at the moment in the heroes I
didn't check at all
I only saw that Sweden I think they
against we did they play two played one
one I think he car was still plays on
the ice to see now and then there was a
question why doesn't he I don't think so
by Auschwitz says Germany played
terrible yesterday I don't think so I
think it was okay started it wasn't
specially I mean I mean okay we had like
15 bad minutes at the end of the first
half but other than that it was a pretty
pretty clean affair and the thing is you
have to win those games this is the most
important thing if you play the best
best game and the best match in the
first one year and then and then play
crap afterwards it's it's it's worse
I was totally okay with what they did
Italy's leading okay Belgium it's very
tough that's already a very young mm-hmm
a very high-profile match okay what if I
cook back here it's a bit unusual but
sending this night back and no maybe a
three before I kick low as a step at the
position okay now I'm going G for I
bring the night over to g3 night c7 huh
okay what is he going for and for b5
stuff that's I don't really believe in
that
yeah the Smallville account of
Nakamura's is in inactive for a long
time he really tries for b5 home okay
okay I think I'll go a five spots
like me says he got my ebook on Amazon
the other day okay cool
Mexico against rain maker here my
opponent is seven wins three losses and
a couple of drawers no I'm not working
on a new repertoire book based on the
banker and benoni no I'm not working on
a book at all
at the moment the grand master
repertoire books by quality chance yeah
they are there are excellent the only
issue with the books is that I mean it's
not an issue per se it just that the
level of detail and and the whole depth
of the repertoire books there they are
very very difficult to grasp for for
normal players and quite often I think I
mean I think they are a bit too detailed
bit too detailed in some cases no
Rainmaker is thinking all of Sep here
from from said Estonia I think it's a
STONER
yes so this is one of those Kings Indian
where black is worth on worse on both
flanks the only thing is and typical
King's Indian thing is it's it's kind of
murky yeah the GM repertoire books as
Lawrence lipps SS correctly a good
reference works it's difficult I think
they are difficult as tools in some way
because it just I mean the level of
detail is sometimes overwhelming but of
course they are from a technical point
of view excellent okay yeah I would like
to play Bishop III but b2 is hanging it
still play it but I can go look h2 right
I should I didn't didn't see that move
coming I hope I hope I'm not getting
into some trouble here I yet maybe
Queens III my coordination is not good
yeah the whole I should have had a very
good position for sure but probably I
did something wrong
tarah 23 here nightshift form
what a shame yeah I really miss played
that somehow I think after h.y h.y white
position was fantastic i still have huge
problems here to to move my coordination
is not great but maybe I just need to
consolidate a little bit then still
everything's cool
there shouldn't overlook stuff like that
for example mmm wha - what a shame okay
take this chick here tonight see one
rupee - maybe I don't know yeah he never
should have gotten this kind of activity
took this okay hmm
so Bishop III wants to take between us
okay shouldn't spend too long
it's not that Kiowa like him wants to do
that Bishop f6 okay I don't understand
the move
okay just goes back time or do check
check
Oh didn't see that [ __ ] coming check
check
hmm maybe I should draw I don't know
check it's not chick made unfortunately
check don't see you in oh no we can take
out drinking came looking up DRA our
third check
yeah
tough tough game now really tough I mean
I already went this is this opening
position like here what is strategically
just winning but I couldn't I couldn't
put it away I think white is winning
strategically because King saw a better
Queen side and better I mean it must be
better for white clearly this I cannot
cannot believe this one bit but from
here I must play I must have made some
mistakes this is probably probably wrong
yeah we never some Queen e2 is really
better for white and that makes an awful
lot of sense yeah playing this and
castlelong
okay so let's see get a Z game again
Rainmaker okay
no I've got black against him no I have
never played against John Gustafson over
the board and the Blitz games are also a
long time ago the same for Nick class
whooshing been played Nicholas um a lot
online we played a match also to mention
say I think I wanted to game match and
when they lost the longer match yeah
yeah yeah good stuff Saul is a very
strong bits player don't really
shouldn't I mean the the band to blitz
the steady plays organizing good but
this is some he was one of the best
German Ablett's players for a long while
Oh cheeks there
okay yeah
young Gustafson doesn't like the Dutch
opening it yeah we this is a pretty
normal for a strategic player that you
tend to tend to be skeptical about the
Dutch opening but I mean I'm also more
of a strata district ejek player but but
I don't think the Dutch sir is that
terrible especially a meaning from a
practical point of view it's quite a
good opening if you want to unbalanced
unbalanced the game it makes lots of
sense to go for the Dutch yeah I'm
giving this I didn't care much because I
felt that getting onto the dark square
should be worth something I just wonder
in this particular moment what I should
play yeah I think I'd go there
my Gustavson is only skeptical about the
Dutch opening not about Dutch people
quite the contrary I mean he's on the
record of pretty much the opposite and
as I am I really
I always liked it a lot to play in the
Netherlands and it's one of the best
countries for chess overall I think got
fantastic playing conditions very nice
very nice to play chess in the
Netherlands um okay what the beep here
what is going on here so this one
oh it just takes it okay that I didn't
expect I thought you would Kobe should
be six and now I'm threatening g5 and
this is actually a rather isn't she five
rather uncomfortable he's got this ugly
move but that's it's ugly what's good
yeah group to have seven and then g5
that was right now what a shame you
really shouldn't have gotten away with
this stuff but he will probably ah what
a bloody shame hmm not good not good at
all
and I have couldn't be won but it's just
a check it doesn't do much
and I should have played rook at 71st I
think maybe as got h4 so
you can just play rook takes e3 I don't
see the see the point here rook takes e3
you can just play or I don't see why not
I have a check on b1 but she's got Queen
e1 there's just nothing going on
hmm what is the point drug takes you
three just wins right cookie three
question
okay this one okay yeah at least I don't
have a choice I don't I didn't
understand anything here okay um yeah I
mean okay that also wins it's not that
it doesn't win for some reason he thinks
the route takes a three it's not
possible check between you why isn't it
possible I don't get it I don't get it
yeah it was possible all along
check
yeah of course I can resign him but as
usual I don't like to it's an awfully
bad position okay I can resign it was
very stupid right we check this okay
this this is just ninety two but he
probably has some I actually has C form
okay to have ninety five
this is good young I have some
compensation but it's not enough
okay anyway let's go for in the game
don't worry so much about the game here
how to an alliance
once chess games there's so much
conflicting information online and it
makes sense to analyze your own games
but if you do so don't do it with an
engine just do it on your own and if you
got to some conclusions on your own it's
a it's a good idea to later check with
the computer yeah this is a good idea
actually to do some cubed saying I think
I will try I will play this game against
Grandmaster bamboozler who is that by
the way and we check it's no name some
pretty strong Russian GM I guess yeah
blitz skip it singers a nice IDM I will
try to do that there are some good
players on I mean again the h3 stuff
this current is so popular
see six
okay yeah what kinds of stuff is
possible I'm not going to play this
leftist laughs why do I get requests for
the schlep does laughs this is like the
most boring opening ever
okay bamboozler interesting okay so here
we have a slightly more comfortable
position I think for white but black
I mean blacks position is not terrible
either night a6 I'm going to play Quincy
one double attacking h6 and c6 group
cakes look zoobi it and let's say yes
I'm going to grab that pawn and see what
happens
I mean the schlechte slab is not a bad
opening I'm really not I don't want to
do that farm I actually once made a
series for the ICC and where I looked at
the sloth defense and I had the SH
letter as an option for black the only
thing is it's just not very active I
really wonder what f5 was all about
isn't that just weakening black enormous
Lee I mean he weakens e5 e6 and what's
the big active point he still has c6 and
h6 hanging so not quite sure what ideas
I mean you can't go f4 but ok so I'll
just take c6 here right there's no
particular reason not to take it and I'm
also getting g6 and stuff
hmm okay yeah what is easy moves look
one the maxi one I might also attack a
five even more the problem is also the
knight on a six I think maybe night
eight to seven is an option no this one
okay if I go to see form oopsy 823 the
Queen to f4 is probably not bad
attacking that pawn
yeah I just tried to get a five as well
they're difficult for black to get
something active going as a request not
for the philidor's defense yeah I could
do that but the footy door is not not as
passive as the Stratus enough I think
but anyway um I'm also going to try for
blitz cubed saying I think this idea is
kind of interesting I could have taken
on d5 with the Queen actually as the
knight were saying oh yeah
rook be one it's not a bad move I mean
black has to know nothing anyway him
yeah that's right there is no real
reason why the Philidor is not played on
the top level I mean it is not the most
active of openings and definitely not
but it is definitely playable and it's
played quite a bit by a strong players
in in rapid and blitz chess so it's not
so much an opening that happens a lot on
in tournament games classical time
control games but it is a good weapon
for blitz and rapid for many top guys
before looks a bit strange but if I move
the bishop is godrick d3 rook b3 I'm
sorry
the knight is not so bad it looks at
some important important squares Knight
piayed I have 95 so he cannot play
knight c6 anyway okay
good a huge time advantage in this game
okay wants to go f4 90 to check yeah
maybe just hear the accelerated dragon
yeah the accelerated dragon is
interesting um but I think black has a
hard time to play against the me Roxy
Boyland
resigns yeah like like resigned I think
he got into a really bad position when
he ignore that couldn't see one
possibility it looked really very
difficult for black to handle and so
let's see if there's something
interesting to kibbutz and there are
some good players but they they play
bullet at the moment mostly let's check
the title places are Donald has locked
off now it's not three that much to
kibbutz okay I'm going to play a couple
of more games myself game starting for
ya look at her forward it wasn't really
in doing much ok playing taxi here from
Finland we've got the VLA game oh this
is a strange line him yeah it's kind of
interesting you know 95 is to move that
there or give with a strange line and no
nobody gives a for which should be
really ok for black this is a version of
the the four could be a counter gambit
that looks really ok for black
yeah I'm not saying that there's
something about them some chat about the
maroc seaboard
I'm not saying that it is terrible ho
black I'm just saying that it's
difficult writing immediately returns
stuff which I understand ok I don't want
the part I want to play actively have
possible I wonder if I could play Queen
a5 if I can go Bishop f5 here the funky
idea like a queen takes bishop have to
check Queen a5 might be a little bit on
the dicey side okay what is he up to
Queen B 5 I'm okay I'm canceling
creepy wants to go through five here hmm
- bit of an annoyance I don't want to
trade Quincy maybe I can do this
actually no I like 94 looks good sorry
for that
friends Bishop F - I should switch off
my mom earlier easier said than done and
threatens a couple of things Bishop F
292 we cannot cancel all also easy now
Bishop c3
yeah against the my Roxy point um black
probably should play this light ext4
system the Guru needs a system but I
still think that white has a slight pool
it's just enormous disadvantage in space
it's hard too hard to play against yeah
it's also hard for white to play here I
don't really see what he should do
Bishop c3 maybe but it doesn't look
great either
yeah I don't know Bishop c3 what am i
doing is it like winning for me he seems
to dislike it a lot it doesn't play I
was thinking maybe here I am
get this piece developed and I asked him
about his next move
yeah I can't like it I can win now I
think Jack wins at least material
there's something else
yeah I think I just I just grab stuff
check okay so um the knight doesn't have
many squares no it's just so much of
your 5 or should I say it's okay
ninety-five who should be six um I
didn't see that one coming
it's a bit of a shame okay that's a
question would I call the Alekhine's
defense refuted no of course not it's
perfectly okay I mean white has a slight
advantage but this is nothing special
it's the same kind of thing with many
let's say yeah kind of secondary lines I
mean the elekid's is a sideline or is a
somewhat non-conventional opening but
it's not bad I mean there is no known no
refutation or anything like that okay so
um what happens here 94 is kind of a
mess maybe I just a test of him takes
into don't see I didn't see that one
it's pretty easy very easy move
yeah doesn't that doesn't look good
I don't have a good coordination here
and these pieces are very active shoot
time morning don't like that at all you
might've not see 495 stuff like that
it's very annoying check
I don't have a gauge idea I don't even
know where I'm going with this it looks
kind of awkward
I had just planted the rook is also
hanging there on v---aids
I totally lost control with this
position which was completely winning oh
my yeah and is threatening work g5 chick
made and check check I lose a shame it
was a completely winning position check
yeah I just overlooked rook h3 and after
that it was kind of difficult already
check check check check okay six yeah it
was really stupid I was really stupid
I never should lose that one but I
didn't see root page three and yeah I
think that wide opening is pretty risky
to be friendly about it so let's see
Queens gambit accepted or any cons
defense yeah we'll see if I can get that
in this is kind of it yeah something
that I can do I simply don't like it
much to play lost openings but I take
requests of course yeah somehow I don't
get a game started it's nothing nothing
really good to kibbutz I'm trying but I
mean there is blitz there's bullets but
I don't really like to keep its own
bullet game started okay detected to
have any requests
yeah I could go to you for for one game
playing who bar WG
I don't think she has a name nope has no
name in there but she's a good player I
played her a bit and it was always very
tough and
so playing a sideline he and Sicilian it
might yeah get to some kind of Hedgehog
yep
so we've got the Hedgehog I wonder yeah
early b3 probably not f3 then this also
looks very okay yeah so you really want
to cheeky for in this position okay if
you want to take it for heads this is
risky I think I'm not going to cover
that pawn
so I mean black can just go Bishop d7 of
course yep um and now the thing is I
wanted this I didn't want to give my
bishop let's see the taking is too risky
okay so I've got a couple of things that
I can do 96 is one of them and then the
check twin h5 immediately is also
interesting or Queen G form
should be 4 and then cringy 4 also as
possible that's not as clear
okay I'm going to do this it's not the
same
I may be Knight f6 hmm I didn't really
appreciate Knight f6 here I mean it's
still interesting but I didn't see this
move coming Bioshock Schweitzer says
doesn't Belgium have the super talented
young player the issue is they have a
couple of super talented young players
so yeah you probably yes
yeah I'm just going to put more pieces
near black skin not sure about the
objective compensation but in a
practical game this is pretty tough to
play rook g3 coming up Bishop before is
a possibility here
okay so here there's a couple of things
9600 496 also 96 immediately
oh no that's not you no joke chest not
my highest rated should have like maybe
four or five higher rated ones and some
pretty clearly higher rated anyway let's
see about this I can go look g3u at this
it's a bit of a lame move
okay I'm taking this but it's tough I
really am really not sure him
maybe maybe she can just move the Queen
here
yeah yeah this is interesting
Queens
it is also stronger than Queen d7
because the Queen is protected there
which is very important I mean okay I
can I can take g7 with I can take a fade
off and then I can just take a maid
actually it took me a while to recognize
that but now I'm just material up
yeah I'm just mature I don't know how
about stuff I mean it wasn't really
tough but to see at the end but I didn't
didn't fully understand what was going
on okay
so counter checking time warning okay so
I could actually save my night here if I
want hmm 97 okay so I have two minor
pieces there the thing I don't like is
that all three pieces are unprotected so
I badly need some quick coordination
here if I get night be 695 this is a
winning position but not sure
yeah more or less winning I think you
can the piece is calling that you can
attack the pawns and the rook is not
particularly great iam check
yeah this is booze positions very good
for white and because the pieces
coordinate very well
main issues I was down on the clock not
not anymore check King z5 this checkmate
check check check
yeah it's always tricky those materials
that balances but I thought that this
should be a pretty pretty good good
position for white because there are
weaknesses that I can attack with more
pieces and either the kingside porn
weaknesses are not a big deal I think
what should be a very good team I just
checked it with the stockfish it gives
two point five for white so pretty much
okay what do you gain oh yeah shake yeah
this is always tough I have a terrible
score he's a he's a yeah I don't know
oh and stuff this is a very solid
opening for his tennis usually play some
stuff swindling from one so a bit
surprised that you play such a solid
opening but okay I have a very bad score
one point five out of eight and I think
from those eight positions I probably
had six or seven winning positions and
yeah the score is terrible
yeah let's see what happens in this game
got some reversed beam only type of
thing we know any bank or whatever yeah
I've got many losses on video against a
better set I've lost most of the games I
probably did not upload all of them
because sometimes I scratch recordings
when I curse too hard and this is the
kind of opponent where I probably have
cursed a lot because as I said in most
of the games I was winning now I do
upload videos with swearing but if it's
too excessive I tend to scratch them and
sometimes sometimes I just blurt
something out that I cannot put on a
video
so this looks nicer 93 92 white is
completely yeah he's weakened a lot and
we were interesting to see what he does
he played very actively but weak in
disposition a lot usually I'm behind on
the clock against and not this time I
played very quickly yeah I noticed I
gnarly mom so your shake what about the
football it said over now it's Ally
Belgium someone can someone tell me the
result you'll not see two wins material
yeah I have to have said I have the
autumn swearing against Allah gasps okay
so I can take a 1 here and this is
hanging on f5 also 93 years isms I know
my t3 it's only one to two nil that's
very strong for them I mean Belgium is
really a quite is one of the favorites
in this tournament I think generally
they are regarded as one of the
favorites so very good result it's a
name okay I think I'm grabbing this
I have discoveries here like Knight
takes Bishop described threatening
discover check with the bishop Ian Queen
hangs is 92 and all kinds of stuff yeah
now I can also I can take this one on a
one or this one I'll take I'll take this
work yeah yeah I can take with the night
if I like if I take f1 it's got night h6
stuff so this looks kind of normal okay
he's attacking this but I cannot go here
for the p1 what check white resigned
okay why can you take on b7 tell me okay
there was a rare a rare win against mr.
Yoshiki okay so there was a quickie game
if we have something to kibbutz
willing to kibbutz one long game and
then call it quits today do we have some
cool game they're not really I'm just
checking if we have some cool game that
I could give it maybe some three-minute
game like to kill it the game that would
be cool actually I don't see it we have
they all play play one minute okay guys
I'm going to play one quick game a
three-minute game let's do one
three-minute game with some crazy
opening to close things
huh I don't get a game there's some
quite decent players in the three-minute
pool but I they must have played one
minute him I don't get a game that's bad
probably indeed many people watching a
football or watching the after game
interviews or things like that now I
don't get a game yeah that's it's weird
seems to be extremely deserted the
Puglia at the moment I'm also requesting
a five-minute game that's really strange
starting yeah no I get a five minutes
yet Queens gambit accepted was a request
oh I get this guy I also have a terrible
school 2.5 out of 10 which is pretty
terrible against someone who's not that
high rated I mean like and like my level
but means I should score roughly 50% but
I don't
okay so this winning here Queens gambit
accepted I don't know I wonder should I
have played aged six before Bishop g5
might be M look slightly uncomfortable
already him yeah not not an expert on
the Queens gambit accepted of course
yeah maybe I should have played aged six
this looks a bit uncomfortable I don't
really see how to how to unpin the
bishop and g5 looks extremely weird
Wow I hate this position it looks
completely bad I probably have to play
age six earlier
okay it looks terrible but I don't see
how to play this otherwise I should have
played a normal opening huh now I'm
sitting in this bad position it's not
the Queens gambit accepted this is a
fine opening but I probably don't know
it well enough
I should go age six I guess that pin was
blah yeah this is a possible move I mean
I don't even know if it is good but I
understand why he plays it of course it
looks aggressive he has got a great
score against me blah blah blah so what
the heck I can take before yeah but that
might be yeah it's got 95 coming up
Bishop is seven he takes on his seven
maybe no no that wouldn't work position
is super dangerous
okay I had trollee that doesn't work but
it's tough yeah that I mean 1995 I will
just take and I've got lots of stuff for
the Queen I just decided to take there
now think about it maybe it still works
for tweeny a3 looks dangerous still
that's one of those games that you know
why he didn't didn't see head of it
beforehand but it's kind of works
maybe Niger Queen g3 it's still very
dangerous
this one okay
96 doesn't work
this is hanging on T for this one the
taps I don't have much time a queen age
for what I wanted to go I have six but
this is unfortunately against the chess
rules
Jake age five threatens Bishop f6
immediately maybe this one
yeah it might still be okay
it's a complete mess though I can try
whatever 95 or what if he takes age five
I wanted to go queen g6 okay we have to
play most thinking long it's not a good
idea yeah it's a very tough position to
play
and I deaf sixes bit of a problem there
in 97 as well I have bishop g6 though 92
was also move then I T true king h1 and
he can play Knight f6
yeah Queen g6 this Knight is 7 so that
doesn't work time warning I don't I
don't see it I really don't see a
defense here Knight f6
amazing
I don't know after wherever need to play
with what water what a weird weird game
I never anticipate any move him check a
just regains material now and will be
known time maybe on position as well I
mean certainly possible check check
not much time left
check yep unfortunately whoops check oh
I didn't see that yesterday I didn't see
that one all right you can take what she
doesn't you know okay he doesn't have to
yeah okay that was very tough time very
tough game I mean there is likely that
wasn't working for while at all but it
is just oh it's just super tough to play
what does the engine giving equal gives
equal of all things it was very tough to
play and it's a it's a rope here but the
engine gives equal which is not really
yeah doesn't sound very well neither of
six instead was winning here yeah anyway
it seems like I don't it's not the kind
of person I handle well this opponent
okay I hope you enjoyed the session it
was a I think it's still a good session
at rating wise it was a kind of even
thing but it had some good entertaining
games okay guys I'll be back next Monday
looking forward to see most of you in
the chat again bye bye guys